IT'S TIME TO PLAY FLORIDA-MAN.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
@FLORIDAMAN IS ONE OF OUR
FAVORITE TWITTER FEEDS BECAUSE
IT COLLECTS REAL NEWS STORIES
THAT COULD ONLY COME OUT OF THE
UNBELIEVABLE FREAKSCAPE THAT IS
FLORIDA.
I KNOW-- I LIVED THERE AS A KID.
WE'LL GIVE YOU THE BEGINNING OF
A FLORIDA MAN TWEET, AND YOU TRY
TO FILL IN THE BIZARRE BLANK,
ALL RIGHT?
IF IT'S FUNNY, YOU GET 250
POINTS.
LET US BEGIN.
NATE?
>> BURN DOWN APARTMENT COMPLEX?
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: I'M ALREADY GOING TO
GIVE YOU POINTS RIGHT NOW, NO
MATTER WHAT.
ALTHOUGH THE CORRECT ANSWER WAS
STOP MASTURBATING IN WINDOW.
NEXT ONE.
DAN?
>> FAMILY REALIZED HE LIVED IN
FLORIDA.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: THE CORRECT ANSWER IS
DRIVING NAKED INTO LAKE.
I WILL GIVE YOU POINTS, DAN
SODER.
>> MINE WAS FLORIDA MAN RESCUED
AFTER GETTING LOST IN A BOOK.
>> OH, THAT'S GOOD.
>> BECAUSE THEY DON'T READ.
>> Chris: YES!
>> AT ALL.
THEY'RE STUPID.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
>> GUYS...
>> Chris: NEXT ONE.
NIKKI?
>> FINISH SERMON.
(LAUGHTER)
>> THAT'S GOOD.
>> Chris: I WILL GIVE YOU
POINTS.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA HOW CLOSE YOU
WERE-- PERFORM EXORCISM ON SON
AFTER METH MAKES HIM ABNORMALLY
STRONG.
>> THAT WAS CRAZY CLOSE.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, GUYS.